doesn't it ever wake you up in the
middle of the night a feeling that
someday they'll come for you and your
children I feel a great swirl of pity
for the poor soul that comes to my
school looking for trouble
some believe that the first mutant was
born thousands of years ago he was some
kind of God and he's gonna rise again
you are all my children that you lost
because you follow blind leaders
tomorrow for cigars I'm here now
he always had four followers like Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse together we
will cleanse the earth to the strongest
we'll take everything from them he means
to destroy this world billions of people
killed say can I start the world needs
the x-men splat you're gonna join them
aren't you
I wanted me to get out of the house bar
right it's all of us against a god let's
go to war
forget everything you think you know
you're not students anymore
your x-men
everything they built young fool
Oh sinking like stones all the way
apocalypse needs to destroy this world
let's go to war
everything
built
they saw the end of the world I could
feel all this death Jean it was just a
dream
the forestry
I've been called many things are many
lifetimes right
la Krishna Yahweh ever since the world
found out about mutants there have been
secret societies who see them as some
kind of second coming or sign of God
they believe that tens of thousands of
years ago ancient being was born the
world's first mutant you are all my
chili and they lost
cuz you follow blind leaders but I am
here now I'm here for you wherever this
being was he always had 4 followers he
would imbue with power like the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse got that one
from the Bible or the Bible got it from
him what is it
Oh God he can control all of us
the world needs the x-men that's why I'm
here to fight
not all of us can control our powers
then don't this is war
everything they built will fall and from
the ashes of their world
we'll build a better one
I've never felt like this before
my name's ophelia blah krishna Yaffe
thatof advice does a small tangent